weston-super-mare on the west coast a
spike in coronavirus cases here forced
the local hospital to close on Monday
from today anyone in close contact with
someone who's been infected will be put
into quarantine for up to two weeks if
they're found by the new test and traced
system like detectives the NHS clinician
from NHS tests and trace and the person
who's tested positive work together to
identify the possible movements of the
virus if you are contacted by NHS tests
and trace instructing you to isolate you
must it is your civic duty to prepare
the government is hired 25,000 contact
races including suit and occupational
nurse from Oxford I'm excited to look
forward to the challenges I think
daunted is the wrong word to use I think
it's just really an anticipation of an
opportunity to be doing something that's
quite unique as the name suggests the
system starts with testing if you have
symptoms and test positive you'll get a
call from a contact tracer they'll ask
you for the names and numbers of the
people you've been in contact with over
the last seven days he'll get a text or
an email they'll then have to log onto
the NHS test and trace website to find
out what to do if the contact has been
recent they may have to isolate for up
to 14 days they'll also be email alerts
which will look like this oh if you want
to ignore them you can because right now
there are no sanctions for breaking
quarantine volunteer contact trace of
dr. Bing Jones says that could work as
long as the government gets its message
right almost everybody is really decent
and they really do want to do this but
the fact is that it's a really
complicated chain and it needs to be got
right at every single point the chain is
only as strong as its weakest link so
the government needs to get the
messaging really really clear
in weston-super-mare people are pleased
but where II don't think if it's gonna
keep everybody sighs Ethan it leads us
to leave a more normal life for those
who haven't have been affected then you
know it's not a bad thing it doesn't
bother me at all because I've got
nothing to hide you know as we've seen
in the past that information does tend
to to go into various places and that
that's a bit of a word this is what we
want to get back to and the government
promises that tests and trace is how we
can do it but to make it work will once
again need to resist the urge to go out
brother man thought Sky News